big controversy if you're watching on
the live look in during the commercial
break only show the video Wrigley Field
where foul ball third-base coach brings
the ball over throws it to a little
toddler front row he's got a glove they
missed it and then rolls to a stop some
guns second row grabs it pulls it up
like I think he just found gold and I
don't know if it's wife or girlfriend
he's like yes like he didn't do anything
ideas wait till the ball stop rolling
and then he showed it to her like look
what I got honey so Paulie said there's
a little more to this story because the
little boy looks like he's four or five
misses out on the ball and then the Cubs
saw this and then they sent over a
couple of baseballs and you know he went
home a happy camper
you know Paulie Paulie said there's more
to the story and it's a it's a breaking
story breaking news story David Kaplan
NBC Sports Chicago he covers the Cubs
pre and post game and cap has the the
inside details here cap can you help us
with this breaking news story great sir
great so what happened is apparently
this gentleman in the second row was
caught in this video and it's just
getting treated like Steve Bartman in
Chicago apparently he had caught a few
of these balls that have been thrown
into the stands or a foul pop or a ball
here there and apparently the Cubs
reached out to me yesterday and said hey
we just want to let you know we went
down there with a signed Javy Baez ball
we gave it to the little boy that turned
out that he also had a game use ball
from yesterday that they believed that
the gentleman who is getting excoriated
on TV had given him because he had
gotten one of them and then someone who
was sitting near them said hey totally
you know that guy got two or three
baseballs
the older gentleman and he gave them
away to different people around and so
this last one he gave to his girlfriend
so
yeah hold on cap this is what we thought
breaking news here Dave Kaplan NBC
Sports Chicago pre and post game
reporter saying that the older gentleman
did get a couple of foul balls and
handed those out did the little boy who
missed on the toss did he get one of
those balls Dave we believe that he did
ossified Javy Baez okay
I so we shouldn't feel sorry for this
little toddler so this guy is actually a
good guy that's what we're being told
for people sitting in that section as
well as somebody from the Cubs I spoke
with what was the reaction at Wrigley
when this happened in real time in the
ballpark there wasn't a huge reaction
because people didn't really see it but
I'm on Twitter and on social media it
just blew up to the point where I mean I
tweet a lot and I put a tweet out
yesterday hey the little boy got the two
baseball it's good favored it over 3,000
[Laughter]
crazy yeah this is the Woodward and
Bernstein of foul balls and you've done
it cap congratulations I hope that
they're I hope there's a Peabody or
something in your in your future thank
you Marconi yes yes thank you did it's a
have a good
David Kaplan NBC Sports Chicago Cubs pre
and post game reporter yes Paulie
that being said now this gentleman in
row two apparently grabbed a few foul
balls in game to the kids around there
he's like the Robin Hood yeah in our
morning meeting people were still salty
that even in this incident he took the
ball the roller that is due for this kid
and kept it and gave to his girlfriend
Seton now that you know that this guy
may have been through philanthropic that
he was handing it out to everybody I
think that's his name Phil anthropic
Phil a tropic yeah that that's his name
that he was being very generous with
these foul balls and you're still salty
over this
I'm not salty but I mean the ball wasn't
meant for him as the little kids ball
should have given it back to him and all
of a sudden now he gave away a handful
of these balls he just kept getting them
and he brought in one from the day
before and gave it to the kid like that
doesn't make any sense but either either
way I don't care if he had caught like a
dozen balls it was
for the kid give it to the kid yeah the
kid had a glove and he whiffed I mean
you know that is true survival the
fittest yeah maybe like hey kid here
take this ball go home learn how to
catch yet that was my problem with it
that I would normally say uh you know
give a kid the baseball you missed it
you were like three feet away and you
whipped on yeah you missed it kid
so that was bad and then and and the
reaction of the grown-up like he did
something incredible like he he brought
it up like look what I just got it yes
and his wife or girlfriends like oh my
god you risk life and limb no he the
ball rolled to a stop yeah a couple
things though like he did the kid a big
favor by being the kid who was the
victim here and he got the Hobby biased
sign ball which you had not got
otherwise do you have to know the
relationship was with between the man
and the woman cuz if that's a girlfriend
and they're on a date you want to get
her a foul ball as well keep things no
one in the right direction if it's a
wife and it's anniversary you'd never
know that fall ball go a long way for
that guy maybe didn't even know her yeah
oh yeah maybe he's trying to tell me up
to her maybe he's married and that's his
girlfriend
whoa yes see well he's keep pets there's
a guy sitting to the left yeah that the
dude who catches the ball then patched
that guy on the thigh so mm-hmm
I mean he was clearly with some people
and maybe he hadn't given that other guy
a ball yet and say hey buddy next one's
for you okay I know this this is like
the fifth one I've gotten today but yeah
trust me once for you this kid in the
front row can't catch so I'm gonna get a
couple more of these you know there's no
chance here yes McLovin I'm gonna give
the guy a full pass if that was like a
first date because you know that would
be a foul ball helping you score if you
know what I'm saying if you're scoring
at home yeah you could turn a single
into a home run yeah the park all right
is that gonna do it like the girls gonna
go on a date oh my god you got a you got
a foul boy like you know you didn't
catch it it rolled do a stop and then
you got a foul ball oh I love you
yeah Fritzi I would like to think that
most women would be a lot more impressed
to see the guy that with give the ball
to the kid in front of him and to give
it to that to her
yeah that would mean well this just this
guy is guy he's real
special he gave the ball to the kid as
opposed to giving it to me yeah fritzy
you're the guy who forced Derek Jeter to
call your girlfriend I don't know if for
so I did kind of kind of guilt him you
cheated him but but it wasn't for me it
was to do something special for someone
else I think in that situation I was
that the same as you for me
Todd you're better than that what you
did is bigger than a foul ball what I'm
saying and that's it I think it's more
impressive I think a woman to be more
impressed and more falling in love with
a guy's qualities that would give the
ball to a kid in front of him than to
hand it to her what did she really care
about this ball more than this little
kid is all dressed in cubs with his
glove I don't know she come true to get
a foul ball she may have said you know I
always wanted to get a foul ball at
Wrigley here she's dressed in cub gears
too so I mean she was a kid once yeah
she probably had a glove she couldn't
catch with either
I think that's getting lost on people
here a little toddler there and I think
he needs a little work I need I need
somebody needs to take him out throw
some baseballs for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]